so let's talk about two for example 15
two to three to nine criteria seven
trillian does not trade in belgium
250 5 million 7 trades before the 1909 the
freaks
okay okay okay
[music]
what do you play on the penningers what
happens when  the us and the string thing
we can't turn this entry
okay because astra so functions of the 19
function as well as hro functions there
are no wrong networks here,
chester normally puts tor an eye out
with white money and my sword and
return swap on kohl's red value  of
function and changes expressions the new
york exchange hosted exchange in the new
bedford ok that make some say what
happens when i saw you can follow me and
twitter for interested javascript
bashing thinks though
[applause]